so you're Anna Wyant a stunning
beautiful 28-year-old female painter and
you're dating this 78-year-old man at
first glance you're probably thinking
that oh he's just her sugar daddy she's
probably just trying to Gold dick him or
oh maybe she has daddy issues and you
would be somewhat correct but it goes
much deeper than that see you as Anna
why are very smart and this old dude
that you picked up is no regular old
dude now this old dude is Larry gagan
and Larry gagan is one of the most
powerful men in all of the f art world
he owns G Goan galleries with 19
different galleries around the world
that sells around a billion dollars
worth of art every year making him the
richest art dealer in history with a
reported net worth of around $600
million so Larry G Goan doesn't just
control the Art Market he practically is
the art markets by by all accounts it's
it's it's a healthy Market which means
if you're a starving artist with a lot
of potential you've got your own unique
style but you just can't seem to get the
rest of the art world to see your Genius
and you also happen to be a female and
beautiful then Larry kosan is the guy
you got to get in bed with and that's
exactly what you as Anna Wyant did you
bang the old dude you want his hearts
and boom your paintings that used to go
for $400 each are now being sold for
$1.6 million a 4,000 times increase and
this is not a knock on Anna by the way
most of us would probably do the same
thing if we were in her shoes but how
how can one man take a nobody artists
and blast her into stardom so quickly
well because the art world is dominated
by just a few rich people and at the top
of them all is Larry gagan and Anna
Wyatt knows just how to court him stay
dangerous subscribe for more and this is
how the Fine Art Market really
[Music]
works men like Larry have controlled the
art world for Generations because
they've been the only ones that have
enough money to actually buy famous arts
and they're also the only ones with the
knowledge and connections to know which
art to buy but for the first time ever
things are changing and now finally
anyone can have access to the Art Market
thanks to Masterworks over 800,000
people have joined the Masterworks
platform which grants them access to
invest in offerings from legendary
artists like Picasso Monae and Banky
take the new bosia offering on
Masterworks for example public auction
info shows that works similar to this
new bosia offering appreciated and value
by over 22% annually from 2006 to 2022
so it's easy to see why the offerings on
Master Wars have sold out within minutes
but if you click the link below you
still have the chance to skip the weight
list and start your collection today
click the link below to skip the weight
list now thanks to Masterworks for
sponsoring this
video despite your raw talent you as
Anna Wyatt weren't raised to be a famous
artist born in Calgary Canada to a
lawyer and a court judge you were never
exposed to art or art history when you
were a kid and the only paintings you
ever came across were the ones your
Grandpa bought from a flea markets and
you never really picked up a paintbrush
in your youth at all nobody would have
guessed that when you grew up your
paintings would be worth millions of
dollars it it wasn't until college at
the Rhode Island School of Design that
you really tried your hand at Arts you
began painting as a way to digest as a
way to understand your childhood and
teenage years like a form of therapy but
almost immediately it was clear that you
had much more than just a gift for
painting you were a straightup prodigy
by the end of your first semester all
your focus turned to painting you
submitted your work to an art
competition put on by the National
Gallery of Canada and immediately placed
in the top three by 2017 you graduated
with a Bachelor of Fine Arts before
going all the way to China to a attend a
prestigious art school to hone in your
skills with a rock solid art education
behind you you moov to New York City
ready to get your painting career off
the ground you spent your days working
as a studio assistant for a prominent
painter named Cynthia
talage and all your nights were
dedicated to painting in your Upper West
Side Apartments Cynthia was so impressed
by your work that one day she decided to
give you a shout out on Instagram and
that single post took you from being
practically unknown to having actual
fans and getting a lot of attention you
were taking the first steps towards
becoming a successful painter but you
still had a long way to go by 2019 you
were lucky enough to have your first New
York Gallery solo exhibition and what's
even crazier is that every single piece
sold the highest earning painting
brought in $112,000 but even the
cheapest one sold for 2 Grand this was
very impressive for our new artists as
most artists barely make a dime less
than a year later you got a feature in
New American painters and not long after
that you received your golden ticket
representation you signed with a gallery
called Blum and Po in Los Angeles and
just like that the value of your
painting shot up now they're being sold
at $50,000 each that's a little less
than the average yearly salary in
America for just one painting you were
officially in the big leagues only a
small percentage of artists make it to
this point and yet for you it was just
the
[Music]
beginning shortly after paring with Blum
and pole galleries things started to go
sour a rumor was going around that your
art dealer Tim Blum was going behind
your back he was supposed to be the guy
to make sure your pennies were sold for
as much money as possible but instead he
was allowing Gallery employees to buy
your pieces in advance they kept your
work for themselves and told collectors
that all your pieces had already been
sold out so who knows how much money
they had cost you you couldn't trust him
anymore and you needed a way out and
that's when you cross pass with the
legendary Larry gagan Larry spotted your
work after your very first solo
exhibition and was taken a back with
your style he immediately bought your
piece head and hung it in his home but
it wasn't until 2021 after you were
falling out with blem and Poe that you
came across Larry again at one of your
shows you were this beautiful talented
young artist and he was one of your
biggest admirers it sounded like
something out of a ' 90s romcom and just
like that you and Larry started dating
soon he was taking you on luxury
vacations to Sano p and Paris and he
immediately started working his magic to
up your value in the art world in the
blink of an i you dropped Blum as your
art dealer in s with kosan Galleries and
your art career started storing faster
than you could have ever imagine
imagined all of a sudden your paintings
were worth millions everyone wanted to
work with you news outlets were
plastered with your pictures calling you
the millennial butelli Europe pece
summertime I sold for $112,000 Just 2
years ago was now being resold at $1.5
million that's right the exact same
paintings so for 125 times more Larry
helped you blow up to millionaire status
and made you a household name in the art
World in less than a year he gave you
what millions of other artists could
only dream of but how how did Larry gag
Goan do it what was his
[Music]
Secrets just like you Larry G Goan
wasn't born into money or the world of
luxury arts in fact he insists that it
was a complete fluke that he got into
the art business at all Larry was the
only son of an Armenian family in Los
Angeles his mom was an actor and singer
while his dad was an accountant he had a
happy upper middle class life and after
earning his bachelor's degree in
literature not Arts he started working
random little jobs to pay the bills he
worked at a talent agency before he was
fired then he took a job parking cars as
a ballet Larry had no idea what to do
with his life until one day he saw a guy
in the street selling posters and the
guy was making a decent amount of money
from it and it sparked an idea for Larry
an idea that would go on to make him a
multi-millionaire he thought why can't I
do that too so he did almost immediately
he realized he had a knack for selling
posters they were going so fast that he
couldn't keep them in stock so he
started framing them and charging
upwards of $100 a piece now he was
really making money Larry made so much
money off of posters that he quickly
earned enough to buy a whole frame shop
of his own and it wasn't long before he
opened another storefront selling art
prints these pieces were way fancier
than the posters he was pelleting before
and it slowly transitioned him from
being a street vendor into an art dealer
but Larry knew the only way to make a
splash in the art industry was to go
through the artists themselves so he
took it upon himself to cold call a
photographer named Ralph Gibson whose
work he has seen in an art magazine
offering him the chance to do a show at
a spot in LA and the the guy actually
said yes this one phone call will
forever change Larry's life all of a
sudden he was becoming friends with
important people in the art world he was
buying artwork and putting on shows for
all sorts of artists on The Rise soon
Larry had become so successful in the
art world that he outgrew LA and moved
to New York where he started buying more
and more expensive paintings Larry might
not have been an art guy at first but he
was now and combined that with being an
insanely talented salesman and business
person and it propelled Larry to become
the richest art dealer the world has
ever seen it put him in a position where
Larry can take a nobody artist and
display their art next to other million
dollar pieces in his galleries he can
connect them with all the right
magazines he can get their art into
auctions Larry can even bid on their art
to drive up the price and that's
probably exactly what he did with his
lover Anna but it might not be all
sunshines and rainbows for Anna moving
[Music]
forward you see artificially popping up
a new artist like Anna Wyant can
sometimes lead to a quick burn outs as
one art critic put it the art World
loves to devour its young and from now
on there's going to be a lot of pressure
on Anna to keep pumping out million art
pieces if Larry Gan backs you you have
to live up to his expectations which can
be a lot right now Anna Wy is living
every artist's dream but all her success
could disappear just as quickly after
all if one man has the power to give you
all the money and fame he also has the
power to take it all away that is just
the nature of the business success is
often fleeting a lot of people will
shame Anna for playing dirty like this
but the world is a dirty place and most
of her haters would do the exact same
thing in her
[Music]
position